so what is it like that's the question
you should always be asking about the
present the hell is this like and every
day in every edition of the New York
Times somebody will tell you that it's
the 1930s and then in the Washington
Post somebody will tell you that it's
the 1970s but I'm here to tell you that
all these analogies with the mid
twentieth century are of no use at all
because the structure of the public
sphere has been changed so much by the
internet that it's nothing like the mid
20th century our time our time most
closely resembles the period after the
late 15th century when the printing
press are you laughs sir that's what I
like to hear incredulity because it's a
typical American response that anything
that happened before the United States
is irrelevant to the history of the
United States you're wrong you so wrong
let me show you how wrong you are
nothing has happened like the impact of
the personal computer and the internet
since the advent of the printing press
and here's the proof if you look at the
impact of these two technologies it's
incredibly similar the effect of the
technological innovation is drastically
fruit to reduce the cost of producing
content and drastically to increase the
volume of content these two graphs are
the same one for the printed book the
other for the personal computer what's
the difference the time scale history
today happens 10 times faster than it
did at the time of the printing press
but that's the only significant
difference except for one more I'll come
to you so the better analogy for
thinking about our time is not 1930s
it's not what again
that's all very interesting but we live
in a different time we live at a time of
massive technological disruption of the
public sphere and most of us
underestimated especially those of us
who cling to old ways of getting
information like newspapers made of
paper we underestimate the extent to
which our time is a time of
communications revolution as dramatic as
the time of the Reformation oh yes this
is a scary analogy it is not a funny
analogy sir it is a bloody terrifying
analogy because when they introduced the
printing press into Europe everything
was going to be awesome
Martin Luther for it was he just 501
years ago said if everybody can read the
Bible on a printed version of the text
in their own language everything will be
awesome we didn't quite use that that
worked what he actually said was will
achieve the priesthood of all believers
the Bible speaks off not quite what
happened what happened was that yeah
Martin Luther's sermons were rapidly
spread throughout all of Europe thanks
to rapid production by printing presses
but so were books like the malleus
Maleficarum which argued that witches
live amongst us and have to be burnt a
stake that book the malleus Maleficarum
the hammer of wickedness was one of the
bestsellers of the 16th and 17th century
that's a good example of fake news and
it's a good example of something going
viral that is a good deal more harmful
than a cat video you know how it is that
people always wanted to tear down
statues these days have you noticed that
and rename things iconoclasm is a
typical products of a disruption of the
public sphere suddenly we must if face
the icons of the previous era
that happened in the period of the
Reformation too as in this illustration
of a church getting a full Protestant
makeover in Antwerp and 1566
polarization in the 16th and 17th
century escalated rapidly from verbal
violence you're a heretic no you're a
heretic no you are a heretic into actual
violence the threshold between verbal
violence and actual violence is a very
fragile fence and they crushed it and
they spent a hundred and thirty years
crossing it the Wars of Religion that
persisted from the peasants revolt that
followed Luther's Reformation all the
way to the end of the 30 Years War in
1648